[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka your brother from
another mother who also happens to be
your sister in this video we're breaking
down the episode 4 trailer for house of
the dragon after the big battle in
episode 3 there's gonna be some major
change ups in the series and throughout
this video we're gonna be going over
everything you need to know about the
new teaser full spoilers ahead so if you
don't want anything potentially ruined
then i insist that you turn off now
unlike our breakdowns we will be
discussing future book events to give
context to what we see so turn off if
you want to go into episode 4 without
knowing anything by the way huge thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
the episode 4 trailer
from my blood
come the prince that was promised
and his will be the song
of ice and fire
okay so the teaser starts off with
ronira reading what appears to be a
scripture imprinted under the valerian
steel dagger we already know from
episode 1 that this prophesizes the rise
of the white walkers and it also states
that a targaryen has to be on the throne
when they arrive this is known as the
song of ice and fire which is the name
of the franchise overall this was
initially shown in a dream and it's a
secret that's been passed from king to
king throughout the ages to warn of
what's coming now we hear the phrase the
prince that was promised which is a term
often used throughout game of thrones to
describe this prophesized character one
thing you might not know is that the
word prince in high valerian is actually
genderless and therefore can refer to
both a male and female character setting
things up to either be dany or jon snow
it all just depends on who you want the
prophecy to be about and initially
melisandre believed that the prophecy
spoke about stannis but after he was
killed she changed her tune and started
thinking it was about jon he of course
died and came back but other red
priestesses believed it to be dany this
is why one visited her at one point in
the series and basically played up the
idea that she was the chosen one i feel
like this series is sort of backdoor
mending some of the events of season 8
and i can imagine that it will likely
end with us getting a full focus on the
dagger spoiler alert but all of these
characters are of course dead come the
end of the first season of game of
thrones so it will likely be the only
item that really ties over from this
into that i'd love it if melisandre
showed up at some point due to her being
able to appear youthful and she could
take the dagger herself and pass it on
to the new guys or all old guys
the house of the dragon will stand as
one for a further generation
who will it be
the brother
now from here we could do a character
running past the dragon skull of
valerian located in the red keep this
was the location that viserys delivered
the original dagger speech at and it
could be tying into that scene with us
seeing another part of it in case you
don't know valerian was for saris's
dragon and after he died the king
decided not to take another one
typically dragon riders would get others
but we've seen through his black dread
statue how he prefers to be without due
to the close connection that he had with
it he watches viserys takes his crown
and then see damon show up wearing his
own if you've been watching our
breakdowns and you'll know how we've
talked about how this came about but if
you haven't then the next part of the
video is for you also subscribe yet why
aren't you watching the breakdowns
now in the book lord corliss promised
him a kingdom in order to make him
invested in the war against feeder after
numerous victories he was crowned king
of the stepstones in narrow sea which is
why we see him wearing a crown here he
actually returned to the kingdom during
one of the great tournaments and it was
also at this event that the green and
blacks were formed whilst it all seemed
like a power play for damon he actually
ended up handing over his crowning
kingdom to him back the favor of his
brother can see that definitely being
something that happens in this entry
with him giving the crown over to the
king in order to be allowed back into
the kingdom the brother they name me
king of the narrow sea
the daughter
your courtship is at an end so i can be
a remedy for your political headaches
you are my political headache
or the little princeling of three
now over the top of this we also hear
the different airs and according to the
subtitles this is said by a street
performer interestingly you might also
know that they say the little princeling
of three which is a reference to aegon
last episode centered around his second
birthday so this indicates that the
episode will have a time jump of about
one year and there's also talk of a vile
rumor circulating through the realm and
we see two hands pressing on top of each
other my guess is that this is the room
and that damon and rhaenyra will have
slept with each other which was a big
part of the source material the books
talked about how he'd seek her out of
the castle whilst she was dressed as a
page boy and the pair would then go to
brothels it is possible that we might
even see this in the teaser with us
getting a shot of damon wearing a cloak
and also ronira running in disguise this
appears to be through the streets of
king's landing and we catch someone
bursting up a fireball this might be the
scene in which the street performer
talks about the heirs but let me know
below exactly what you think now the
story of damon and ranira sleeping
together is filled with second-hand
accounts in gossip namely from the
character mushroom this is someone who
doesn't appear in the show but in the
book he's basically a jester that
spreads rumor throughout king's landing
mushrooms said that the pair got it on
and there was a number of reasons for
this initiative was thought they did
this because damon was telling her how
to seduce sir kristin rather to say they
just did it because they were attracted
to each other his talks of the pair also
flying away together to far away lance
but that they could run around naked
together and yeah there's lots going on
there mate now rhaenyra is clearly
denying that any of it is true and it
might not have even happened in the show
canon in the book she threw herself at
sir kristen but he ended up rejecting
her and she ran off into the night she
actually ended up sleeping with sir
lionel's strong son who she bumped into
and he's the character that the books
says took her maidenhead basically a
maidenhead is your b cod and that's for
anyone who wasn't born in westeros or
the 13th century now ono appears to be
telling viserys about this and it could
end up being a rumor spread by him in
order to have her ousted the book
constantly talked about how he tried to
get ranira pulled down as the heir so
that he could probably grant an a gun as
the next in line
also they say aegon in the show i'm just
calling him aegon because that's how it
was raised now both he and allison have
been complicit in the seas for power
with them conniving away to get her
close to the king in the book there's
also the groundwork there for them
trying to get this plan enacted with a
pry king jiharis the story talks about
how when he was on his death bed that
alison would venture out to him and read
him stories in the night in his old age
he started to believe that she was one
of his daughters but there might have
even been a possible play by the pair
there to get her close to him before
viserys came along thinking about that
though they kind of changed up the
timeline a bit with allison being 15
when she did that whereas here she was
15 when she went to viserys a bit of
timey whimey nancy onesie wibbly wobbly
stuff but i'm just showing you how
things happen now it seems like they're
going to try and force ranira into a
marriage after this as we see her
attending court beside her we can catch
a character wearing the baratheon sigil
as well as sir kristen cole and someone
up front who i don't think i recognize
i have discomforting news
this
is a vile
accusation
who is responsible for this gossip i
will take their eyes
it is not in raniere's nature to be
deceitful i cannot say the same for your
brother
the teaser ends with a dragon swooping
in and this seems to be carraxis aka
daemon's dragon we can tell this by the
red scales that it carries which are
typically associated with the creature
this could be the group sailing out to
take part in the courtship and damon may
end up racing ahead and even putting
himself forth to marry raniera in the
books he tried to take her hand in the
marriage after the brothel stuff and he
said that it was targaryen tradition for
aunties to marry nephews and nieces to
marry uncles so he could be flying out
there to attempt to stop the whole thing
but it is still pretty early on in the
timeline for that to be happening either
way that's everything we noticed and
could decipher in this brand new look
the show is changing things up a lot
from the books so these predictions
might not even end up being true however
i do think the rumor thing will be about
damon and ronira as it seems to be
centered around the ladder this is
roughly the point in the timeline where
that took place so that would be my
guess for the whole thing overall now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so make sure you comment below and
let me know we are in a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of top gun maverick on the 15th of
september and all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our brighton of episode 3 which will be
linked on screen right now we went over
the whole thing from top to bottom
talked about all the callbacks to the
books all the things they do differently
and it's definitely worth checking out
right after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
poor let's see in the next one take care
peace